what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
oh my god Rob poor man I'm sure some man
trace enough
this story's amazing not only tell you
something not okay okay do this this
story man this comics an emotional
roller coaster like it is just it is so
good oh my god it's some of the best
stories but man if God was right in
college right now is what it would look
like right now it is it's so good okay
okay so let's lift let's get into this
all right let's let's let's talk about
this so what we end up dealing is we
actually kind of go back maybe by about
two or three minutes before Bruce Wayne
and Barry Allen show up in the
flashpoint universe and really what
Thomas Wayne does just kind of give us a
recount of what it wasn't having a
flashpoint again you guys are welcome to
check those videos out those video
should keep you abreast of everything
that's going on but the idea is that
we're basically just kind of told that
you know where we initially thought the
war would end you know with regards to
the death of eobard thawne with very
Allen going back in time to allow his
mother to die to keep himself from
saving his mom's life where that
initially just kind of jump-started the
new 52 we were left to believe that
flashpoint ended that that was just a
pocket universe the universe was created
when Barry Allen saved his mother's life
and the universe was destroyed when
Barry Allen allowed his mother to die
but what we end up fighting out here is
that's not the case
flashpoint kept going on and it
shouldn't have it should not have gone
on at all it should have stopped it
should have ended it should have just
been cut off from the source but the
problem is that it's still floating out
there and not even Thomas Wayne knows
why Thomas Waynes is kind of like you
know this shouldn't be here anymore the
reason for why this universe existed has
basically been undone the universe
should have vanished with it not only
that we end up finding out that because
flashpoint still exists the war between
the Amazons and the Atlanteans just kept
going Aquaman and Wonder Woman are still
at war now eventually they end up
joining forces against Thomas Wayne
himself because of the fact that Thomas
Wayne try to lead an insurgency against
them and basically bring him down but
the issue here is that within his own
home within what's left of Wayne Manor
he began planting all different kinds of
explosives so that when his back was
against the wall and there was no other
choice he was going to blow it all up
and take himself with it and at the
moment when he's getting ready to hit
this button the flash and Batman show up
now this is she
huge because this is the first time that
Thomas Wayne and Bruce Wayne meet each
other this has never happened and it's
such an emotional moment between the two
of them because he'll remember Barry
Allen seeing all this he's met Thomas
Wayne before he was in the flashpoint
universe they're not new to him
but even Barry Allen says it shouldn't
be this way things shouldn't be like
this this universe should be gone
someone somewhere it's keeping this
universe alive and so again further down
the rabbit hole
we're just tumbling down that rabbit
hole alongside Alice because someone
here has so much power somebody out
there presumably dr. Manhattan has so
much power that they can control and
maintain universes as they see fit so
that's kind of the crazy scenario here
is because what we also end up having is
that where so many questions are being
asked so many things or more or less
being hinted at we end up finding out -
the questions more or less kind of have
to be touched short and the reason why
is because of the fact that the forces
of the Amazons and the Atlanteans are
racing down to take out you know Thomas
Wayne and end his insurgency and so of
course again the funny thing about this
is remembered Thomas Wayne in the the
flashpoint universe was a lot more
ruthless and violent at Bruce Wayne he
did not have the same kind of restraint
and that worked just because of the fact
that instead of a child losing his
parents it was a parent losing their
child and that has a way of shifting
people in a fundamental manner
that makes them drastically different
than the way they used to be really it
was like Thomas when he looked around he
lost his wife who became a joker he lost
his son who was murdered there was no
reason for him to even care anymore as
we did whatever was it he had to do and
we're gonna try his best to restore some
order to everything that's going on but
not only that for the Batman fan and
indeed even for just like the general
color book fan we get to see Batman and
his father Thomas Wayne fight alongside
one another and it's so cool to see this
because what we end up doing of course
is basically had Barry Allen repairing
that cosmic treadmill you know of course
the SuperSpeed and that kind of thing in
order to basically get themselves out of
there now at this point you know what
these forces are you know more or less
subdued there's this really beautiful
moment between Batman and his father
Thomas really Thomas kind of begins
talking to Bruce about the memories or
at least memory that they mutually share
with regards to their own past
experiences now this is really important
the reason why is because in the
flashpoint stories we never really got a
whole bunch of really in any in-depth
analysis in terms of what the history
the characters were like before the
events of Flashpoint in relation to the
main DC universe all we got was
basically hey here's what led up to the
flashpoint story you know led to the
events in the flashpoint universe and
that was really about it but what we end
up finding out is that there was a point
where the memories really the the
timeline of the DC Universe for Thomas
in the flashpoint universe and Bruce in
the main DC Universe were exactly the
same the divergence was presumably when
Barry Allen never became the flash and
so because of this you know they end up
talking about a you know when when Bruce
Wayne fell down the cave now of course
we don't get super in-depth into this
instead you know what we end up finding
out is of course you know Thomas was
whispering for the most part because he
didn't want to you know disturb the bats
and kind of cause panic or anything like
that but in the midst of them having
this conversation getting ready to
basically go about their business
someone presumably just wipes out the
flashpoint universities begin the
process of eroding at all now again this
is just a crazy display of power I mean
just an astronomical display of power
but we still don't know what's going on
and even burying kind of hypothesizes on
this was it a singular being out there
who was keeping the universe alive and
chose to go ahead and allow the universe
to die was it almost like they had their
foot on the gas and on the brake and all
they had to do was let off the brake and
that car was just ready to go or is the
universe just kind of wiping out now is
one of these things with with regards to
Barry Allen's actions that when he went
when he went back and allowed his mother
to die the effects of his actions and
basically eliminating the flashpoint
universe are just now catching up to
things and the universe is just now
beginning to be wiped away they don't
know what the answer to that question is
the implication is that a stock to
Manhattan who's just destroying that
universe but we don't know but in this
last little bit of a conversation and
this is when the story gets so emotional
and this last little bit of a
conversation Bruce Wayne tells us father
Thomas you have a grandson I have a son
named Damian you know you have a
grandson and this is when things begin
to radically shift because worst
beseeches his father to join them to
come with them to get them out of there
and one of them happening is Thomas this
just kind of pushes him you know under
the cosmic treadmill and tells the flash
to get him out of there and this is
where really I think the stage is set
for the future of what's going to happen
with the Batman concept Thomas
basically tells his son stop being
Batman you know what I had you I knew
that I'd made all the right choices
because it led me to you like I know
that I made all the right calls because
I had you
as a son and that year that you're the
greatest gift that I ever could have had
but he says don't be Batman be a father
let go of your anger let go of your pain
let go of your struggle and your strife
let all that go and just be a man
be happy be a father for your son in the
way that I never could now what this
seems to indicate is that we're going to
see Batman kind of taking his father's
words to heart and maybe just vacating
the landscape maybe walking away and the
stage is being set in a lot of different
ways for example in Nightwing in the
what does that not really much die
storyline the one that we just covered
Damion Wayne's whole irritation is the
idea that Nightwing will take up the
mantle when Batman retires instead of
Damian himself we know Duke is being
trained for something in particular
all the roads really seem to lead to
this idea that Bruce Wayne is going to
vacate the wall about an or maybe he
won't maybe he'll just stay Batman you
know maybe he'll just be like you know
I've got to live up to the legacy of
what my father did and that kind of
thing we don't really know but in these
moments you'll in these final moments we
end up having this this beautiful
segment where we learn what it was that
Thomas said to his son when Bruce fell
down into the cave and Bruce asked the
question why are you whispering and
Thomas said because we don't wanted to
disturb the bat Bruce of course
apologized by saying I'm sorry I fell in
the cave his father responded by saying
it's okay sometimes we fall but remember
Wayne's never stay down and then like he
just charges headlong into this conflict
he's like rear eyes and it's like the
coolest thing because we all know what's
on the other side of this light all we
know is that something's there and
regardless of what it is
Thomas Wayne is just fearless the guy
goes out like a hero just runs headlong
into whatever it is that's there
presumably his own death and at the end
of him and the universe that he resides
in and so it's just this incredibly
emotional moment because it's Thomas
Wayne meeting with a son it's Bruce
Wayne meeting with his father it's the
two of them being able to reconcile and
while Thomas had so many things he
wanted to say to his son the main
message was sent across go find
happiness stop living this life of anger
and misery and deceit go be a happy
person stop letting the death of myself
the death of your mother dominate your
life just go live and so while the
question is being asked what in the
world happened we end up having like
eobard thawne racing up behind it now
again this kind of ask the question
where did Ivar
come from he was supposed to have been
dead of course you know basically have
that man answering this question for us
so this is eobard thawne before he ended
up hilt in the Batcave itself and so you
know this is one of those things where
eobard thawne can exist essentially in
two places at the same time now we don't
know where he's coming from all he says
is that he's seen who it was that this
button belongs to he knows the power of
the person that this button belongs to
he knows what they're capable of
they've never faced someone like me now
this has huge implications for the story
because what this does is this asks
several possibilities we know by virtue
of the solicitations for the flash
number twenty two the fourth part of the
story the final part of the story that
it seems like Jay Garrick is going to be
involved in some former fashion whether
it's his return whether it's his debut
whatever the case may be he will be
involved in some way now if eobard
thawne were to meet Jay Garrick right
off the bat he'd be able to figure out
Jay Garrick just not fast enough to keep
up with him [ __ ] doesn't know about
him Jay Garrick's you know just too
honorable to Goodweather case maybe but
Jay Garrick has never faced anybody like
eobard thawne that's a possibility it
could be that eobard thawne met one of
the Watchmen maybe he met the comedian
before he died maybe he met Ozymandias
you know and his idea is well hey
they've never faced anybody like me I'm
so dangerous I'm so crazy they'll never
be able to stand against someone like me
maybe he glimpsed the power glimpsed dr.
Manhattan you know maybe dr. Manhattan
doing something or just kind of meddling
about his own business any of our Thawne
underestimates the power of dr.
Manhattan and simply says they've never
faced anyone like me before they've
never faced anybody as powerful and as
crazy as my abilities are I'm just that
good at what I do now in truth that
final option with the whole idea of dr.
Manhattan that is the most logical
scenario one because of how he apart
Thawne reacted freaking out talking
about how he saw God - because eobard
thawne is arrogant enough to
legitimately believe that no one like
dr. Manhattan had ever seen a power like
his before and that as fast as he is and
as capable as he is that he could
somehow overpower dr. Manhattan those
are entirely possible ideas but as we
know just by virtue of what we saw in
the second part of the button that does
not work out in his favor that's sure
he's very arrogant sure he's very cocky
but his actions get the better of him
and eobard thawne ultimately dies but
with that being said guys we are going
to bring the
to an end if you are new here to come
this explain make sure you hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah
this story's amazing story is so good
and I will catch you guys later peace
[Music]
you